now that disney's latest live-action
remake of one of its animated classics
is here
fans are digging into every frame of
mulan to find all the amazing easter
eggs
but while some of them are obvious like
the lucky soldier named cricket the
discussion among the troops about what
girl is worth fighting for and the cameo
by original mulan voice actress ming na
wen
others are a bit more subtle here's a
look at some easter eggs you missed in
the live-action mulan
in the animated mulan a falcon is a spy
and scout for the villain shan yu
who leads the han army to attack the
emperor the bird is a prominent
accomplice
even beginning the whole film by
signaling the attack against the
emperor's troops
the live-action version gives villain
bori khan a similar aerial accomplish on
a hawk which provides reconnaissance and
perches nearby as he organizes
his troops the animated bird didn't
speak to sean u
but the live-action version communicates
well after transforming back into her
human form
veteran chinese actor lee gong plays a
sorceress who
like this version of mulan is strong
with the power of chi
described in the film as quote boundless
energy for life itself
the makeup props and costume design keep
the bird motif throughout
from her talon-like throwing stars to
her headdress and flowing like sleeves
that almost look like wings
all a callback to the original film's
animated avian
in the animated film mulan's family
guardian is a great stone dragon which
the ancestors urged mushu to awaken to
protect the young woman once she leaves
for the battlefield disguised as a man
while trying to rouse the beast to
transform from a statue mushu
inadvertently breaks off the statue's
ear then shatters it
out of guilt and self-preservation the
little dragon sets off to assist mulan
instead
in the live-action film mulan's family
emissary is the phoenix and early on
mulan accidentally breaks their phoenix
statue just like mushu
her father finds her outside after dark
trying to fix it and delivers a lesson
about the power of rebirth
considering how mulan sees a colorful
stand-in for mushu at several key
points later in the movie the phoenix
clearly doesn't hold a grudge
the name mulan means wood orchid and
this film like the animated version
uses floral imagery to refer to the main
character notably in both versions when
mulan goes to meet the local matchmaker
she has a comb with a jeweled flower in
her hair
then when mulan decides to join the army
in her father's place
she leaves the comb on her parents
nightstand in both films to say goodbye
the live-action film has additional
references too as mulan's mother and
sister help her dress for the meeting
with the matchmaker the soundtrack plays
the melody of the animated film song
honor to us all
whose lyrics revert to mulan as being
like a lotus blossom
soft and pale plus mulan's makeup is
more elaborate here than in the animated
version with a lotus blossom adorning
her forehead
later as mulan secretly bathes away from
the troop garrison the camera focuses on
the blossoms of a nearby tree
calling back to a very special
father-daughter moment in the animated
film when mulan's father points out a
tree blossom that hasn't opened
but look this one's late
but i'll bet that when it blooms
it will be the most beautiful of all
the theme of the animated mulan depicted
through the standout soundtrack song
reflection
is being true to yourself as the lyrics
say when will my reflection show who i
am inside
as she sings mulan wanders into the
temple where her family prays to her
ancestors seeing her reflection in the
memorial stones there
she later looks at her reflection in her
father's sword then uses the sword to
slice off her long hair
before she joins the army the
live-action mulan doesn't cut off her
hair before wearing her disguise but she
does look at her reflection in the sword
at a few key moments
etched on the sword are figures for
loyal brave and true
three virtues representing her family's
honor and qualities mulan aspires to
exemplify
whenever she looks at her reflection in
the sword the audience knows she's
wondering if she's reflecting these
virtues
i will bring honor to us all during the
climax of the animated version mulan
saves the emperor by helping her
colleagues spirit him to safety
she then faces off against shaun u on a
rooftop as he lunges at her with his
sword she disarms him catching the blade
in a hand fan and then pointing
it back at him a bit of visual irony
about outwitting him with her feminine
wiles
the live-action mulan also battles the
villain during the climax of the movie
of course
and in a fun visual callback to the
original she also races across the
rooftops
and well we can't say much more without
spoiling the ending but at one point
they even end up facing off on top of a
giant wooden beam just like in the
original
you might even say that with all these
fun easter eggs the new mulan is a loyal
and true reflection of the original
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you